every time you make an action
any anything with action you're
surrounded by men what i love about this
is it's all women kicking ass
uh can you sort of talk about that
aspect and is that one of the things
that
one excited you about the movie uh yeah
it was
the thing that excited me about the film
was that you know
not only are there you know six women um
majority of them are kind of over 45
which
is fabulous uh
i loved in the third act there is a slow
motion tracking shot
that uh involves a lot of you guys i
love that shot so much
can you talk about uh filming that and
what
that specific shot um yes
i mean that was heavily influenced by a
korean film we all know and love
um and we we worked on that for you know
a good
couple of weeks just to time it all out
because there were so many people
involved and it was as you say it was
one tracking shot and also novot had
um music uh that he wanted he knew what
he wanted for most
pieces so it was a really specific
rhythm for that piece
um but i love that i think it turned out
great
yes it is i rewatched it yesterday and i
was like yes
this is a great shot um
uh i always love about learning the
behind the scenes in the making of a
movie
so what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of this
film
i mean it's obvious when an actor isn't
doing a fight
uh you know there are some pieces that
are kind of acrobatic
and um unless you're an actor who has
trained in the circus or
uh stunts for 20 years you're not going
to be able to pull it off but
we all did most of our stuff as
much as we possibly could
uh yeah i did notice that it also helps
when you have michelle in the movie
and she's kind of good he is the goddess
the og she's incredible to watch
yeah i'm pretty much if you cast her in
a movie it's basically saying i will
watch
yes you know it's pretty much like that
so
you've gotten to voice evil lynn a few
times and
you're also doing it with kevin smith's
upcoming masters of the universe
uh what do you love about voicing evil
lynn and what can you tease people about
this
upcoming masters of the universe uh well
i'm actually going in tomorrow to kind
of
do the final pickups um but listen
kevin smith is a dreamboat and
uh i always enjoy projects
uh where the director is so invested and
so passionate
and you can only be inspired by that
and kevin is like that about this series
he loves it
um and so you're gonna get a huge
chunk of eberlin's backstory which is
kind of impressive i saw the first
episode actually already
and i was surprised at how fast it moves
it is fast
yeah without giving spoilers um so the
other thing is you're doing white house
plumbers
which is uh a series i'm really looking
forward to what can you tease about that
see i don't want to get in trouble um
what i can say is that
i've it's you know rare that you read a
script that you
just um devour but this is such a
smart funny um
piece of writing that it's it's just
really wonderful to be able to
just play around with writing like that
and also you know
i'm working with woody harrelson who is
you know
he helds what else you're going to say
well i actually
i want to do a follow-up on that i've
seen woody work on set and what's
interesting about woody is
every take that i saw was slightly
different
like he's always in the moment is that
the way he's
doing it in when you're working with him
yeah totally
what he's like totally free uh
likes to give you a song a bit like
karen gillan before a take
um yeah he's he's he's awesome he's just
usually barefoot and
uh just playing around
right i've seen this he's great i gotta
stop there i'm just gonna say congrats
on this
thank you so much for giving me your
time thank you